-The president
of the United States
stole classified documents,
which were then
copied onto a private laptop
while he and a close
family member made money
off their dealings
with a foreign government.
Wow, this is a damning story
for President Biden
and his son, Hunter.
Oh, what's that?
It's about Donald Trump
and Jared Kushner?
Well, no, just
thank God you told me, alright?
Because the next
cue card says, "I'm sorry,
Marjorie Taylor Greene,
you were right,
and you deserve my utmost
admiration and respect."
You know what, Wally?
Can you get rid of
that cue card?
-Yeah, sure thing, Seth.
[ Laughter ]
-That was aggressive, Wally.
You could have just
thrown it out.
-Sorry, Seth.
I bet a lot of money
on the Eagles last week.
Luckily, I just made it all back
by appearing on camera.
-Okay.
Gotcha.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Do you want a minute
to catch your breath?
Too bad!
For more on this,
is time for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
Before we get to
the investigation of Trump's
stolen classified documents,
there was big news in another
Trump investigation,
the one looking into
potential election interference
in Georgia.
The district attorney
has already said charges
could be imminent.
And last year, she informed
ex-Trump lawyer Rudy Giuliani,
that he was a target
of the investigation.
Well, today, a judge released
parts of the grand jury's report
from that investigation,
which revealed
that the jurors found evidence
of possible crimes
and even
recommended indictments.
-Breaking news from Georgia,
moments ago,
a judge in
Fulton County, Georgia,
released parts of a report
submitted
by a special grand jury
investigating efforts by
Trump and his allies
to overturn
his 2020 election loss.
-In it, the grand jurors
write that they believe
that at least one witness
may have perjured
him or herself,
and they encourage the D.A.
to seek
appropriate remedy there,
presumably in the form
of an indictment.
-Now, we don't know
who they're talking about
and we can't guess,
but when I saw that news,
this is the face I made.
[ Laughter ]
We'll have to wait for the rest
of the grand jury report
and the DA's final decision
before we can draw
any more conclusions.
But oddly, that's not
the investigation
Republicans are
interested in right now.
Instead, they've been laser
focused on basically one thing,
and that's
Hunter Biden's laptop.
It's been a nonstop obsession
on right wing media,
and the new Republican majority
even held a hearing about it
as one of their
first acts in power.
-Big media suppressed the truth
about the Hunter Biden
laptop story.
-He may have collaborated with
the U.S. intelligence community
regarding stories that y'all
didn't want the public to see.
So, namely, what we refer to as
the Hunter Biden laptop story.
-We're gonna go into
Hunter Biden's laptop.
-There's a lot in that laptop.
-FBI subpoenaed
Hunter Biden's laptop...
-Regarding
-Hunter Biden's laptop.
-Hunter Biden laptop.
-The laptop from Hell, right?
-I haven't seen anyone
this obsessed with a laptop
since my childhood friend
found porn
on his dad's Toshiba T1100.
[ Laughter ]
We burned the hell
out of our thighs,
but it was worth it.
Very steamy.
Also very slow.
"Did someone order...
a pizza?"
[ Laughter ]
Seriously,
the last time a bunch of people
freaked out
this much over a computer
was when Bill Gates
launched Windows 95.
Took 25 years,
but Bill Gates finally
got off the hook
as world's worst dancer.
Dude looks like he's trying
to wriggle his way
out of a straitjacket.
"I'm not crazy.
I just gotta boogie."
Also, why does Trump call it
"the laptop from Hell"?
He's never used a computer
in his life.
For Trump, any laptop would be
the laptop from Hell.
If he ever saw Jason,
he'd probably hear
the Apple startup chime.
[ Startup chime ]
Republicans have been
so obsessed
with this laptop
that Congressman Matt Gaetz
hijacked a congressional
oversight hearing last year
that was supposed to be
about cybersecurity
to relentlessly grill
a dude from the FBI
about the location
of the laptop.
-I want to know where
Hunter Biden's laptop is.
Where is it?
-Sir, I don't know that answer.
-You're telling me right here
is that as the assistant
director of FBI Cyber,
you don't know where this is
after it was turned over
to you three years ago?
-Yes, sir.
That's an accurate statement.
-Have you assessed whether or
not the Hunter Biden laptop
gives Russia the ability
to harm our country?
-Sir, again, we can do
this back and forth
for the next couple of minutes.
I don't have any information
about the Hunter Biden laptop.
-Do you even know who has it?
Do you know who we should
put in that chair
to ask these questions to?
-No, sir.
I don't know who has it.
-Well, could you find
out and tell us?
-Sir, I'd be happy to take
your request back to our office.
-Gosh, I mean, will you
advocate for that briefing?
As -- You will?
-I will be happy
to take your request
back to FBI headquarters.
-Well, will -- Do you believe
that that is a briefing
that the Congress is
worthy of having, I guess?
-Sir, I am not going to
answer that question.
I'm here to talk in --
The invitation says "oversight
of the FBI cyber division."
-I've never seen
a congressional witness
refer to that invitation
like that before.
It's like when you get invited
to your weird aunt's wedding,
only to realize
she's marrying the cat.
"Oh, [bleep].
Let me look at the invite.
Yeah.
No, it says right here
'Mr. Whiskers.'
That's not --
That's never been
a person's last name.'
And the GOP's obsession
with Hunter's laptop
has only gotten more intense
with the revelation
that Joe Biden
had some classified documents
from his time in the Senate
and as vice president
at his home and private office.
Even after Biden
turned over the documents
and welcomed multiple
FBI searches of his properties,
Republicans still want to know
if Hunter Biden
specifically had access
to any of those documents.
-Think about from
his own family,
where Hunter Biden is involved.
-Hunter's proximity, easy
access to classified material
is a little bit more
than concerning.
-Are we sure Hunter didn't get
a look at these documents
or sell them to his business
partners in China or Ukraine?
-It looks like Hunter Biden
was peddling
classified documents for cash.
-Hunter Biden had classified
information in his possession.
-The FBI needs to search
the residences of Hunter Biden
and any business offices
of Hunter Biden
to determine if there are
classified materials there.
-And I'm sure when the FBI got
Ted Cruz's request, they said...
-I'd be happy to take
your request back to our office.
[ Laughter ]
-But clearly,
based on the Republican
obsession with Hunter's laptop,
they're afraid classified
documents could have been copied
to a computer,
where they would be vulnerable
to espionage
or influence peddling.
And that fear turned out
to be totally justified --
just not in the way
they were expecting.
-More classified documents
found at
former President Trump's
Mar-a-Lago home.
Multiple sources telling CNN
that Trump's lawyers
turned over these documents
to federal prosecutors
after they were found searching
through boxes at Mar-a-Lago.
Now, apparently the documents
were also copied
onto the laptop of a Trump aide.
-Oh, my God.
Classified documents
were found on a laptop.
That can only mean one thing.
It's...
[ Voice echoing ]
...the laptop from Hell!
[ Lightning crack ]
[ Evil cackling ]
-AOL Soundbite: You've got mail.
[ Laughter ]
-That's right.
After two years of nonstop
obsessing over Biden's laptop,
someone on Donald Trump's team
reportedly had a laptop
with classified documents on it.
But here's the thing -- say what
you will about Republicans,
they are consistent
in their outrage.
So here's a long montage
we put together
where Republicans
express concern over
who had access
to these documents.
-♪ Never gonna give you up ♪
-That's right,
we did a Rick Roll!
A meme so old, I first saw it...
[ Applause ]
I first saw that on
my friend's dad's Toshiba.
[ Laughter ]
He called me recently,
by the way.
He said he wanted his hair back.
[ Light laughter ]
So Trump has now turned over
more classified documents
he apparently
withheld from the feds.
Now, you might recall
he recently defended
the discovery
of some empty classified folders
as a "cool keepsake."
But a lawyer for Trump
went on CNN this week
with an even dumber explanation
for why
Trump had this stuff
in his possession.
-Now, you also turned over
an empty folder marked
"classified" to investigators.
Where was this folder
and why was it turned over?
-It's a folder,
a manila folder that says
"classified evening summary"
on it.
And it was in
the president's bedroom.
He has one of those landline
telephones next to his bed
and it has a blue light on it,
and it keeps him up at night.
So he took the manila folder
and he put it over it
so that it would keep
the light down
so he could sleep at night.
They demanded it back,
and so now the president
has to find a different way
to keep the blue light
out of his eyes.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, best of luck to him.
That's right,
Trump claims he kept
an empty classified folder
as a way to cover a blue light
on the phone
next to his bed
so he could sleep.
The guy's supposed to be
a billionaire real estate mogul,
and he lives like
a hungover private detective
from the '70s.
Just drinking [bleep] beer
in a trailer on the beach
with a gross, old dog.
"Come on, Honcho. Bedtime.
Now where's
that sleeping folder?"
What other federal documents
is he using
to fix [bleep] at his house?
Did he patch up the screen door
on his patio
with a copy of
the Declaration of Independence?
Oh, I'm sorry,
I don't buy that
he couldn't sleep
with a blue light next to him.
This is a man
who stared directly at the sun
during an eclipse.
I doubt a blue light
from a phone
can pierce his retinas.
Also, I simply do not believe
he sleeps
in pitch black darkness.
He's definitely one of those
old guys who's got the TV
blasting all night
with his iPhone
right next to his face
at maximum brightness.
When Trump walks
into his bedroom at night,
I bet it's like Kramer
walking into his apartment
when the chicken place
opened next door.
[ Loud humming ]
Now, as we've discussed
many times on this show,
it's one thing
to have classified documents
in your possession
and return them when asked.
That's what Biden
and Mike Pence did,
and it's not that big a deal.
But Trump repeatedly lied,
defied a subpoena,
refused to give them back,
and instructed
aides and lawyers to say
he'd returned them all
when he hadn't.
That's why he's being
investigated
for obstruction of justice.
And now the investigation has
reportedly gotten so serious,
the special counsel leading
the investigation is trying
to force one of Trump's lawyers
to testify again by suggesting
Trump may have used
that lawyer to commit a crime.
-We're learning that prosecutors
who were investigating
Trump's handling
of classified documents
are now seeking to compel one
of his attorneys to come back
and testify
before the grand jury again.
That attorney is Evan Corcoran.
He's already testified
before the grand jury
for about 4 hours or so,
I'm told.
But they actually want him
to come back.
And this time,
they are trying to overcome
that attorney-client privilege
that protects what he and Trump
have talked about privately.
And in doing so,
they have written to the judge
alleging that they believe
Trump used Evan Corcoran in
furtherance of a crime or fraud.
And that's a big deal --
prosecutors are basically
saying that
attorney-client privilege
shouldn't apply, because
the attorney in this case
may have helped
Trump commit a crime.
But I mean, come on,
that's ridiculous.
When has one of Trump's lawyers
ever helped him
do anything suspicious?
Oh, right, I forgot Rudy,
the guy who looks like
he just walked into
Donald Trump's bedroom and was
blinded by the blue phone light.
"Whoa!
Boss, we need to cover that!
How about we steal
the Mona Lisa from the Louvre?
Oh, looks like she's smiling,
eh, boss?"
"So what?" you might say.
So he has some classified
documents and empty folders.
Republicans say the difference
is that Hunter Biden
traded on his name
and connections to make money,
and surely no one
in the Trump family
ever did anything like that.
What? Oh, they did?
Dudes, come on! Again!
Thank God you said something.
The next card says,
"And that's why I'm endorsing
Matt Gaetz as the next president
of the United States,
because he's right.
And also,
dudes with large foreheads
should stick together."
Wally, you can get rid
of that card, too.
-Sure, Seth.
-You're not going
to rip that one?
-Nah, I'm gonna take it home.
Need something to cover
the blue light on my phone.
-Okay.
Oh, so now we're letting Wally
do callbacks?
Okay.
[ Laughter ]
Anyway, turns out --
and wait for this, shocker --
the Trump family was allegedly
trading its name
and connections in a corrupt
deal with the Saudi government.
-According to a new
Washington Post exposé,
"The day after leaving
the White House,
Kushner created a company
that he transformed months
later into a private equity firm
with $2 billion
from a sovereign wealth fund
chaired by Saudi Crown
Prince Mohammed bin Salman."
And ask for his father-in-law,
"A year after his presidency,
Trump's golf courses began
hosting tournaments
for the Saudi fund-backed
LIV Golf.
Separately, the former
president's family company,
the Trump Organization,
secured an agreement
with a Saudi real estate company
that plans to build
a Trump hotel
as part of a $4 billion
golf resort in Oman."
-Corruption aside, that sounds
like one of the worst vacations
I could possibly think of.
"Hey, honey, I know you wanted
to go to Paris this year,
but great news.
I got two tickets to
the Trump golf course in Oman.
We're going in June.
It's gonna be 120 degrees.
Better get your --
Honey, you're not
saying anything.
Do you want to go?"
-I'm not gonna answer
that question.
[ Laughter ]
-Also, Kushner reportedly
started this fund the day
after he left the White House.
I'm sorry, it doesn't get
any more corrupt than that.
He got $2 billion
from the Saudis,
who he did
official business with
when he was in the White House.
And curiously, Republicans
don't seem too concerned.
The only way we can
get them interested
is if we take this "Closer Look"
and email a link to Joe Biden,
asking him to forward it
to his son
so that the evidence
can be found on --
-Hunter Biden's laptop.
-This week alone, we found out
from both the special counsel
investigating Trump's handling
of classified documents
and the grand jury looking into
election interference in Georgia
that there may be
evidence of crimes,
but Republicans remain obsessed
with one dude's laptop.
I have no idea if Trump
will ever get indicted,
but if the cops
do show up at his house,
I hope he has
some folders around to --
-Keep the blue light
out of his eyes.
This has been "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]